your girlfriend Diane Kruger beautiful
was on the show a while ago and she was
talking about you and she started
talking about your first date and in
this is a classic and it relates to the
affair because like he said she said but
according to her you picked her up for
you for the first date that you had yes
and you went out and you did all the
talking and then she said you talked
about yourself and then you guys left
the restaurant and after what she
thought wasn't a great first date you
went in for a kiss which she didn't
think was appropriate appropriate yeah
that was her story she told that sitting
in that chair oh I know now this is your
now yeah because I then you know she
comes home like really that's the
romantic story you tell about us so let
me tell you what actually happened yeah
what actually happened is you know I'm
inviting this very beautiful European
woman out to a first stage so I called a
friend I was like I need a fancy
restaurant and I get a really nice
Italian place so I get this restaurant
I've never been there before I booked it
I'm feeling pretty proud of myself we
get there and she immediately starts
having an allergic reaction to whatever
the pretty flowers were in the place and
so she starts like sniffling and
sneezing for the next hour and a half
what else am I supposed to do the
choices were sit in silence or vamp as
I'm sure you know sometimes you just got
a vent so yeah I might have talked a
little bit too much at dinner but I was
just trying to keep the conversation
moving and then why not lean in for the
kiss right I mean though if she's
sniffling in a an allergic reaction if
somebody literally like breaking out in
hives that's not what I like time to go
in
give me a little bit of that anaphylaxis
[Laughter]
yeah well I like okay I hear your story
now and I feel like it's unfair that she
didn't annotate any okay and then on top
of which the it's a German thing she is
she was she's from Germany she's she's
all German 100% and can't help herself
that is that was her telling of a
romantic story for her that was a very
sweet telling of that story right and
she misses out the sweetest like I
didn't actually romantic thing
afterwards the next day because we'd had
such a miserable date and I figured I
was never gonna hear from her again I
sent her a box of flowers with a Kleenex
in it I thought I was like that was
really nice that's very sweet
somehow that doesn't make it into her
telling story also what if she doesn't
misinterprets like with the cleaner who
knows me I know you're giving it flap
yeah hanging a flower two Germans yeah
like fair bill just died yeah that was
actually her yeah I was like she
literally was like why would you give me
these I'm leaving town they're just
gonna die yeah yeah now then it took you
a long time before you actually started
that date that bad date set you back set
me back I put me deep in the friend zone
right there was like an almost two-year
digging out from under that two years
years yeah God you were persistent yeah
why I mean it wasn't in a monastery in
the meantime but yeah
well now see to it she gets a clip of
yes interview nicely I'm single again
yeah three boxes of Kleenex
you